we are in the call 8 phone bank
answering questions your questions about
medicare enrollment the annual
enrollment period is coming to a close
so it's important that you know whether
you want to update your plan or if
you're enrolling for the first time this
is the time to do it these good folks
are going to be here until seven o'clock
tonight answering your questions
702-650-1101
and while they're going to be here until
seven the best time to call actually is
right now because the phone lines aren't
super busy in the three o'clock hour
that but as we go on throughout the
evening they start to warm up we're
joined by rick scroggs with alignment
health plan thanks for being here rick
thanks kendall glad to be here tell us
about a lyman health plan sure a lyman
health plan is an award-winning medicare
advantage plan that's here in clark
county this year and we're expanding up
into nye county and into reno in 2022 as
well as bringing a couple of new
products a dual which is for that
medicare medicaid person and a c-snip
which is for that chronic person for
either diabetes or heart so we've got
some very exciting things coming well
it's so important to know which medicare
plan is right for an individual because
they really are tailor-made according to
certain needs what is a medicare
advantage plan that's a term we often
hear and what makes alignment health
plan different well i think the most
important thing to know about a medicare
advantage plan is that it's bundled into
a one-stop shop if you will we take that
part a of medicare part b and that
prescription drug part d and we bundle
it into a medicare advantage plan so it
makes it real easy for the member to use
they're just showing one card when they
go and the question that i love about
what makes alignment different it just
we have a way of just focusing on the
members health we want them to be
healthy we're going to do everything we
can in our plan to help them along the
way by taking out some of those big
copays like mris and cat scans for zero
copay we want them to get their tests we
want them to stay healthy it's great
advice and feedback that people are
getting here by calling this number
again they're going to be here till
seven tonight and we'll be back a little
bit later here to talk more about this
rocky you kendall thank you so much